entscheide dich z.B lieber für den Beruf
des Anlagenmechaniker SHK das steht für
Sanitär Heizungs- und Klimatechnik in
dem Beruf fehlen nämlich 60.000
Fachkräfte klar das ist ein bisschen
auch der Herr Robert Habeck Schuld daran
weil ich weiß nicht der ist eigentlich
immer schuld wenn irgendwas mit der
Heizung kaputt ist weil der hat da
irgendwann glaube ich schon mit dem
Hammer drauf gehauen habe ich schon
gezeigt und gesehen also ich bin schon
festlegen trotzdem fakt ist es gibt nur
noch halb so viele Azubis wie vor 20
Jahren warum will keiner mehr das machen
ich zeig's euch das ist voll einfach
schwer hallo
könnten sie das freundlicherweise für
mich heben ich habe einen Test
habe ich wirklich
[Musik]